hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to one-shot Nico I'm
back I'm sorry
hey markiplier welcome back thank you
and welcome you guys back to one-shot
now we just got our necessary to love
the library access card and I don't know
if we've combined it with our photo I
don't think we have and we're gonna put
that okay come on knows plenty this the
back of the photo is covered in glue
which I got [ __ ] did I do something bad
everything is still okay okay
everything's fine and glitter okay so
now that is sticky and I can plop that
on that one the Carn is my face on it
now so it's now kids library card so I'm
pretty sure that we can take this and
then we can take it all the way the
library which means that we're going to
be able to do everything that we need to
do to be able to get through the library
and meet the head librarian now I don't
know who the head librarian is but I'm
hoping that they're going to help solve
the mystery of this book that we have in
our possession now if there are other
things that I missed I don't think there
are because I think I explored just
about every territory I even went back
and I met with the person who built
silver out in the Barrens and silver is
the robot that was based on that
scientist and probably one of the first
ones to be tamed by whoever is the
author not me not my old character the
author but the author of these books
authenticating barcode executing facial
recognition so to match successful
you're good to go alright thank you have
a nice day miss kit uh maybe I should
have changed the name yeah who's gonna
know I mean could I have known do I have
anything they could have done that
I got a feather no ink for it so I guess
that's fine all right miss Kip come
through oh my me
there's no idea what is gonna leave me
hello
it's full of garbage looks like an old
phone huh a small tree what do we have
to say about all this a small tree okay
all right then keep coming through Helen
oh hello dad you must be the Savior
Oh are also the cutest darn thing I've
ever seen
hey thank you can I help you with
anything sweetie mm-hmm oh no what I
should do next I think I'm supposed to
go in the tower oh that's right the
tower I know there's a small room that
you can go into but I'm afraid nobody
knows how to get in beyond that not even
silly only who spent an entire time life
reading books about the world ah I think
you need some help from markiplier but I
don't know any details I've never found
any books about this before do you think
there'd be at least one book on this but
I guess it's society's goodness this is
quite a dilemma I've got a book mr.
markiplier here's got a book for you
he's also one sticking out here
a book is punking out from the shelf
another privilege is a great profit
today she seemed to be in high spirits
she told me that she saw another glimpse
of the Messiah's arrival more vivid than
ever before the Messiah will wake him in
a dark house he said the vision include
lights from window and the sound of
footsteps on wood floor regrettably she
is unsure of the houses location
rockiest is meeting with is also present
at the meeting I ended up visiting his
house later and we swap notes
he's been very vigilant on recording the
prophets day-to-day musings and his
writings have been significantly more
legible lately his children were
endearing as ever the older child
calamus has expressed an interest in
reading i offered to teach him as did I
as I did his father oh well that's nice
but I'm gonna get into those from just a
second because I've got this strange
journal then I'm gonna see if she knows
oh if you have this book I think it's
written in some sort of words I don't
recognize really now now take a closer
look dear here oh oh my
did you find this somewhere in the
Barrens found in a pile of dirt next to
some robots skulls is great we found it
in a safe right markiplier yeah don't
mention me in public
hmm I think I'm supposed to translate
this for you is it alright if I hold
onto this journal for a while sweetheart
it might take a little wild I'm afraid
go for it excuse me oh you poor baby
goodness you must have worked so hard to
help us I think you deserve a nap no the
NAB does sound nice I've against room
upstairs it's just down the hall to the
right
aren't you sweet thank you so much a
book sketch book of some sort another
still life of some objects on my desk
still not very good but silver can
recognize the objects at least Thursday
various sketches practice huh so this is
some cab I think that's from kick
book pointing out hey book is actually
about clovers oh those pigmentation is
primarily black the leaves display
incredible rear Destin's when exposed to
sunlight these curious plants are most
resilient and can even thrive in the
metallics and in harsh climate to the
bearings in the gland can also grow
directly on top of Moss layer without
competing with the moss for resources
radiocarbon dating of fossils exist
these plants may be the first life-forms
to colonize our world
that's a little weird why are these
things here and why are they so Hardy
this bizarre the bokeh book is poking
out thankfully dr. Selbourne scheme is
able to replicate our prototype on the
right is an updated sketches some of the
modifications of external design more
importantly we used radically different
architecture for the microprocessor due
to limited resources this time but it
still should be capable of delivering
the late profits message the teams
suggested that aiming was a lost cause
oh well that's sad so the profit is dead
the profit is long gone I see you've
taken an interest to the manuscripts
what are they formed well aren't you
curious with one the author passed these
drafts to me you see since I'm the head
librarian I supposed to help them puzzle
is finished but now I haven't seen that
gentleman lately which is quite strange
usually it delivers these manuscripts to
be faster than I can work on it
I guess now it just means I get a little
more breathing room oh that's good right
I don't know I am quite worried about
him I hope he hasn't fallen ill from all
that stress at least I got my hands full
for the time being even though he stops
telling me things it doesn't feel like
he did at all
the pile of manuscripts I still need to
proofread doesn't seem to get smaller ha
ha excuse me
black clover on the book huh they all
about clovers of course Nadia the black
clover is sort of the author's name you
see huh actually we don't know his name
he just uses a clover the Marquis works
assault so he wrote all these books he's
a trooper that that's not a trooper
that's inhuman is the box I'll get to
publish this week oh did I mention this
gentleman's books are quite popular you
might be a little too young down the
Scanlan but the only kids love them Oh
what is he right about lots and lots of
things everything from plants and
animals to everything in between
some of his books even have pictures
ah good friend is full of bottled water
take out help that nice gentleman is
alright if I knew where he lived I would
have sent him some super a nice blanket
the bad gentleman is all right if I knew
where he lived I would have sent him
some super nice blanket okay you feed
yourself there printer computer says
something about updated database is
small bad I guess he lives here nothing
really to see here huh
even the painting is books not sad I
keep a copy of every single book I help
them publish feel free to read anything
you'd like to it there's a couple of
picture books that you might be
interested oh oh that's all I have to
say about that I'm not emotionally
attached to anything going on here oh
but it's time to go to bed blank papers
full of manuscripts full of manuscripts
blank papers and a book on the ground
but she deeply believed in the
multiverse theory regarding alternate
versions he likened the probability to
rolling a dice recently I found that
theory easier and easier to believe but
I would not describe it very well back
then nevertheless I still wrote it to
the best of my abilities after all it
felt only right to honor this way there
are six which one did you encounter well
he said something to me are you talking
about here me dragging around back I'm a
little tired from walking yeah take a
nap and God everything's gone gone away
oh my god all yours Oh cute Oh Oh what
is that an egg nothing's weird whoa
scared I had a new egg
sorry Oh nightmare
hey markiplier I guess you saw my dream
yes it was skew Lea come on let's go oh
come on you can talk about an ego just
don't let that light bulb drop away it's
the lifeline of everything in this place
huh had a good nap dear mm-hmm
wonderful I've translation ready for you
now it looks like this journal might be
meant for markiplier oh here where do
you take a look
ratings rough [ __ ] greetings market liar
if you can finally read this it means
you're near the tower the tower is the
domain of an elusive entity this being
is connected to the world for now you
can think of it as the spirit of the
world it has no physical form but it can
communicate through computers and other
machinery you know who I'm talking about
of course the author when you first
arrived here with our Savior it no doubt
contacted you right away through its own
means the entity will guide the both of
you to the tower the entry room is at
the towers banks not only do you need
the Sun Bear but also three pieces of
the previous segment the savior will not
be able to do anything there you
markiplier on the other hand look at the
pattern on the floor do as it says the
window will be gone so you need to bring
it back that is all there is to
translate looks like the other pages
have been torn out Oh quite a shame I
was wondering what window is supposed to
mean oh well I guess markiplier can
figure that one out cuz I'm so smart
right everybody trust me because I am
the smart one right well what does it
mean three pieces of the previous Sun I
only have this son
that means the stuff containing yellow
phosphor the glow for a very long time
so people call them pieces of the Sun
sometimes
oh I do have a piece of amber and a
feather
they're both glowing yellow very good
dear and I can help you with the last
one
it's your eyeballs but actually it might
be oh good it's not my eyes oh nice oh
it looks like you I know isn't it silly
now you'll have something to remind you
of the library ha thank you
good luck now sweetie I wish you safe
travels well okay thank you glad I don't
have to rip my legs out because they're
glowing yellow all right so where do we
go from here we have what we need we
have three pieces to bring of the quote
unquote old son back if that's what that
really is but then where do we go
because I need to figure something else
out here
hey Morgan are you remember where the
cafe is yes oh good I'm asking because
well I'm a little hungry actually I'm
really hungry haven't eaten anything
since I got here taking a lot of nap
with no food it's okay if we get some
food before we enter the town I hope
they have pancakes I guess yeah I think
yeah I'm assuming yes huh so that means
we're going to go back up the elevator
so I guess that tells me enough where
I'm supposed to go after this I think
I've explored all that there is for here
talk to pretty much everybody but I'm
still wondering what it means by it said
it's been guiding me all along what does
it mean by that like is it talking about
the red blocks and what not because the
red blocks first appeared when I open
that safe and found that book so either
the spirit of this author guy that
everyone seems to enjoy so much
describing its own world with his whole
people
as Mark Millar likes silence don't talk
to nobody don't let nobody talk to you
yeah I like it but first before I go
anywhere else I'm gonna check on this
plan because a lot of you guys were
worried about this plan and I know I
were saying that you need to try the Sun
on it but I did try that so it wasn't
that I think it might have just been a
time thing but I also have this
enchanted water with this enchanted
water maybe I might be able to water it
with that and then it'll never need
water again you've given it dirt and
water what will that be enough but maybe
this medicated good thing in markiplier
its water should really help this seed
grow sploosh
splitter see its product a tiny leaf oh
good luck little plant okay now I'm
gonna try this okay so this is the sun's
ain't working but now it's sprouting
because apparently it never needs water
again ain't that a handy-dandy thing for
a plant looks like Mays is going to grow
back big and strong so either either the
spirit of this world is the pixilated
blockiness or
it is this author unless they're the
same thing I don't know
or it could be whatever this taming
process is okay now bear with me that's
a bit more of a stretch but bear with me
this training process known really
understands it but it's the thing that
makes robots seemingly able to be human
that's a little weird you know you gotta
admit this a little weird that's not my
first option but that's why it's my
third one but it's interesting oh hey
you're back to command to fix the
elevator mmm and miss market buyer and I
went to the service already and I'm
starving give me free food uh well I
remember there being a cafe here do you
have pancakes
we sure do wait I don't have any money
maybe I can help you wash dishes or
something no no no no it's on the house
the least I can do for the save you're
right here why don't you take a seat
I'll go fry some up for you
pancakes pancakes yes oh hell yeah
these pancakes are so good thank you so
much no problem
you look really hungry yeah I thought
this would be my last chance to eat
something before I go in the tower ah
gotcha so I guess pancakes are your
favorite food
well almost my favorite food in the
world of the special pancakes that my
mama makes she likes to pick hazelnuts
and grind them into the batter oh wow
that sounds amazing they taste amazing
she always made them when I was feeling
sad we're lonelier Oh mom I really miss
her oh I just I just have a bad feeling
all of a sudden am I even here to save
the world
oh people have been saying other some
won't fix anything I don't even know why
I'm here I just want to see my mama
again oh uh they're there it's gonna be
okay and I'm sure you'll be able to save
the world you're a tough kid you managed
to get this far already right yeah but
you're good to go home afterwards right
right hey want some more pancakes it's
okay
I'll be fine
I don't think Nico's going to be able to
get home so yeah thanks for coming by
mm-hmm thanks for listening and for the
ban cakes no problem
good luck I sometimes forget that this
is just a kid look this is legitimately
this is just a kid the kid is here and
for what reason plucked out of his home
for nothing else than to save this world
that apparently doesn't want to be saved
like this world seemingly is ready to
die by all accounts the inhabitants are
just like there's some people that are
struggling like the scientists are
trying to figure out what they're doing
I don't know hello again Messiah you
need help need to find a way to get the
library on the service well I already
did that so I'm just going to go over
and see what's going on with the plant
see if it sprouted any more I don't know
if it would have and I don't know what
it's going to do if it does now that's
all there is and there's really nothing
else to do because they got the glowing
amber the glowing dice the glowing
feather huh weird
so all this yellow phosphor that they
call it is like as close to the original
that they have blue phosphor being out
the Barons green phosphor and the Glen
and then red phosphor here in the city
so I guess the only way to go is to make
my way to the tower I don't even think
that I could take a map anymore
because I mean considering I just got
one so now I'm just basically stalling
done we should get going to Alberta
Blair okay I get it I just feel so bad
for Nico what's gonna happen to him is
he gonna go
I'm he's gonna go to the tower obviously
but where's he gonna go all this is
quiet now you better not say a word he
go
you know I demand silence not it got a
peep
mm-hmm oh that huh Bernard said nothing
to me all right fine okay okay good
so as I requested okay so now where do I
go what do you have to say huh you all
right the Messiah
oh yeah he's the same thing yeah yeah
it's the same thing that he said before
so I don't remember if there was any way
that directly took me to where the tower
was I know there was those doors that
were locked from the inside like that
one just down there but I don't think
that's where I'm supposed to go so I'm
gonna carry through the alleyways here
and hopefully I'll find something lead
me to where I need to go there was that
bed in here that supposedly someone
lived in these alleyways I don't know if
they're here yet a big book says
understanding robots I don't know why
anyone would be here understanding
robots there's a note thank you for
working so hard mr. Lamplighter and then
that's all there is so I guess what we
got to do oh and there was that robot
that was trapped just like trapped in
this like the glowing grayness please do
not approach so weird if that is the
spirit of the world maybe it's like
maybe it's like that's in its death
throes like it can can't seem to live
anymore what's that sorry about why is
that tree there there's a lot of
mysteries in this game and I feel like I
may have missed something here and there
but other than that I've been pretty
thorough about at least as far as my
expertise goes so I guess the only place
you go is try to get to the tower
wherever that is so I'll be right back
when I find it
whew oh okay that opened up I didn't
expect that to but I guess there's gonna
lead me to the tower maybe the music is
lovely here hello is there someone in
the darkness waiting for me
who is at the tower oh my god that is
isn't it that's just the frickin tower
it's right there maybe I shouldn't call
it the frickin tower it seems to be
awfully nice there's nothing hidden back
there okay so you I just walk in I guess
I do what else would I do
where does this lead though I want to
find out oh maybe this oh ah that led me
to the door the one I just commented
about before the alleyway okay so I
guess all event I need to do is I need
to go into the the tower and and I don't
know my instinct is like to save and
like try to try to do this right but I
only got wore x-x-x
on action as hard as I can
what do i X I'm trying to ask nope
okay right then oh you you talk about
you talking about this X the one that
closes out the program it does get read
[Music]
oh hey hi what the hell is happening huh
hello Oh dark so I understood it
correctly I was supposed to exit out of
that this is the inside of the tower
it's a lot darker than I thought
wait where's the Sun uh-oh make out
Marga bar do you know what happened to
the Sun uh Marga blar I'm here to go
bargain Blair
come on markiplier say something I'm
right here I'll don't break my heart
like this burglar doesn't do what's
going on
oh no can I move I can't
I've got no items where's Nico where's
Nico oh hello hi hello hello Nico hello
congratulations you're now inside the
tower are you talking to me now
correct but you were always talking -
markiplier before where's markiplier has
already left no that's a goddamn lie
I had to resort to contacting you
directly
wait so markiplier is gone just like
that correct no I'm here for good
correct
no Marga Blair has already finished
their mission and so of you Nico here
you can rest now everything that's
happened here is like a bad dream when
you wake up you will be home oh but
what's wrong I thought there'd be more
to it you know I thought we were
supposed to go to the top of the tower I
thought that was supposed to be
somewhere we need to put the Sun in and
now I don't even have the Sun anymore
markiplier is just gone this feels wrong
but you did good you saved the world
Niko are you not happy I guess I am but
it's just well this doesn't seem right
someone get IT down here right now I
have a funny feeling of sleeping in that
bed is probably last thing that I need
to do I need to wander around find an
answer to this there's something fishy
going on and oh god no oh oh yeah [ __ ]
well I got nothing I can't fast travel I
didn't even know I can fast travel
before but apparently I really can't
okay
so is this the only option I never even
got to say goodbye to markiplier and as
for you all okay as for you markiplier
we're done here please don't return to
this world anymore
hey how about you don't tell me what you
do okay how about you yep I'm coming
back good huh now go leave Niko behind
like that okay my desktop changed this
is not over regardless of what the
entity told you there's more to the
story
oh the computer is the entity duh oh I
don't even think of that documents my
games one shot look for the symbol once
it is active relaunched the game see you
soon okay
now we're getting into the thick of this
wha oh [ __ ] okay so that's active I got
that up now Savannah I just got to go
back to what job right I think
hey it's dream
Nicko oh hello markiplier yeah it's me
was that you just mouth I thought I
heard your voice I'm Aaron a go in my
dream I'm here I guess you're still not
there
alright here they go wait there's
something in my pocket I don't remember
putting it there what do you have to go
aha I've got a clover that ain't so
black no more dr. dot you're still here
Nico why are you still here you what did
I do
that's creepy why did you come back
markiplier I told you to stay away I
knew I tried to cut the story short oh
you knew you knew that I do is that it
you want more out of me is that it fine
you don't want to leave I'll make sure
you never do I like that a lot less okay
wait a minute wait a minute oh okay
alright okay so we got we got something
new here now okay so we got that note
this note here there's something cut out
of it and Nico is in the middle of who
God knows where oh that's weird
oh that's super weird oh wait wait wait
is there like oh my god please tell me
this is how this works
please tell me that's how that works who
wait No if I do this oh my god oh my god
please tell me that's how that does Oh
what the hell happened Oh some change
whoa
apologies for that I did not want to put
the librarian in danger uh okay
put that over that apologies for that I
did not want to put the librarian in
danger so what you're saying is the only
way to go is up once that's there that's
what that means
the only way to go is up uh okay
all right then hibbity bibbity be oh my
god now we're getting into think of this
the only way to go out is up here as
well this being has a habit of silencing
the people who want to learn its true
nature oh is that so well I'm about to
be a learn into individual and you're
gonna tell me all your secrets that's
what you're gonna do regrettably I
haven't seen it happen to dear friends I
have seen it happen to dear friends the
overlay is telling me to go to the right
you got it buddy boo I'm on the way
oh hello ah but do not worry the entity
cannot touch you no are you talking
about me or Niko here okay good god this
is getting so cool okay so the only way
out is to go back just the way I came
all right you got it
ooh alrighty then
nor can it do anything to me and who are
you or you're the author do the author
are you the author about this you're the
author about this whole thing maybe
[Music]
let's see I already left the world on my
own terms
I see okay that's that's in the pictures
a little more jagged in this one
oh hello I never meant to the entity to
exist oh so are you something that's
like the entity as well I'm assuming
this is the author here and I'm assuming
that there's something like I okay but
now now that it's fully sentient one
thing became clear what one thing I'm
guessing you're pointing to the right
door there so I'm gonna go on that one
yeah baby the entity seeks death as in
the entity wants to die really I said
death to itself death to the world a
relentless desire that manifested
physicality wow you've already seen the
scars yeah I have whoa this heavy [ __ ]
oh man right now the entity is doing
everything it can to impede your
progress stalling for even a few minutes
wait which one was that okay got it
cease before you have in evidently bring
the Sun to the towers summit so that's
what everybody meant by saying this
world was dying they were all feeling it
if that's the spirit of this world then
every inhabitant would feel that death
approaching and them it's there like the
darkness that you would feel about it
why does this entity desire to death
that's where you God will make the final
judgment for the world I just wanted to
be a silly god that shouted a lot I
didn't want this kind of responsibility
Oh God me ha me I'll be now our God me
of course the entity will contact you
again there in that door and when it
does it will trick you into shattering
the Sun this will end the world
instantly
Oh dot the dot dot you know that means
instant curse pollution instant curse
bleep wait oh there's a secret door oh
there's a secret door down there in
there oh no ok it wasn't a secret door
dr. dot dot dot dot identity 2.2 dot no
no it's not that simple
what's not that simple what are you
talking about this is not the author
giving me instructions anymore I'm sorry
I do not know what to do in a situation
like this are you talking about
no no no no no no no it's not that
simple
ok so there's a puzzle going on here
sorry I don't know what to do in
stitches like this all right I did the
wrong one never mind I mean I am dumb I
died I thought it was one and it was
another I see but I think I have to tell
you the truth ok well I mean if you do
you do oh the Sun is the Messiah's tie
to this world
Sherman even if ativy really live lamb
done and done
I don't know what that did as long as
the Sun is intact the Messiah remains
trapped here Oh
no oh don't put that responsibility on
me
oh no Shiva DB DB DB definitive blah
blah rim okay so that's what that means
if I want to save this world I would
trap Nikko here
shattering the Sun may terminate this
world but boy it is also the only way
for the Messiah door turn home oh don't
put that on me oh dude I don't do that
oh do that oh no oh no okay got that
oh no I do not realize this could end up
like this
please forgive me oh no no ah it's the
Sun oh oh it's the light bulb thank
goodness it's safe dot dot
Eko I guess markiplier isn't coming back
Mikko I'm here markiplier yes is that
really you I thought you were gone is he
I never left you
oh I was feeling a bit scared back there
I thought I was completely alone but I
was silly of me to assume wasn't it I
guess we need to figure out where to go
now
Oh Sun it lit up on its own
[Music]
I guess we should pick it up right Mauro
Kay I thought I was waiting on you Nico
there all right then one the hell oh no
where am I in that basement again oh I
am how do I get back here oh I am back
here but before everything got decrepid
alright
colorful my favorite channels I guess I
keep down I guess damn everything here
is fine nothing in the fridge
it's zinc what is neatly stacked in the
fireplace man is so weird and here's
this place it won't turn on yeah you
know what talk at infinity added finicum
not ad infinitum ad finem which I
believe ad infinitum means forever
infinity but a definitive means probably
only once or something like that it's a
little tree mirror that big eyes you
ever gone to the bathroom either Nico
you holding that amazing bladder and
whatever that light is coming from is it
from the Sun outside the other thing
that's happening so you actually made it
here okay that's creepy I guess you win
markiplier I'll tell you how to save the
world then when you reach the summit
shatter the light bulb end but I think
that I saved the world hmm
jiggly jiggle jiggle jiggle
I'm just humoring you I know you've been
getting help from a certain someone he
already told you about the choice didn't
he yeah I kind of did yeah you really
did yeah it's a doozy are you still
planning to save the world markiplier
why are you trying so hard for this
haven't even figured out what this world
is a game is that what you're trying to
say - I told you at the beginning your
mission is to help Nico
leave but Neko isn't part of this world
Neko is the only thing worth saving here
the final choice is up to you I can't go
against my programming
it hasn't been tamed you only have one
shot markiplier aww if you choose the
smash light bulb the Neko wakes up back
home like it was all a dream
but if you let Nika return the Sun the
child will have to bear the weight of
this sacrifice oh oh that's it that's a
doozy at least tell me code the truth
you do care about Neko don't you yeah of
course I tell me go the truth yeah you
gotta give you gotta give him what is
Neko one why is it on me what does Neko
want to do like that's the most
important thing all right I'm banning my
decree of no talking to the elevator
against this elevator leads to the top
of tower I've got something very
important to tell you to go are you
excited market alert we're finally going
to save the world and I know it's for
real this time cuz you're here yeah I
would like to say something to you and
then I'll get to go home for real this
time too I can't wait to see everyone
again yes I will die are you okay
markiplier you seem a little quiet Neko
yeah I need to tell you something
I'm listening we can't save both the
world and you would what's that supposed
to mean markiplier to send you home we
must break the lightbulb what but won't
that what that in the world yeah I don't
want that to happen
so what happens when we save the world
what happens to me I don't know you
don't what would happen if you just
didn't Callum I'd be horrible
Oh God
ego what do you want it's not my choice
it's yours
so this is where the Sun belongs if I
put the Sun in here we'll be able to
save the world right but if I want to go
home
I'll have to break it Oh markiplier what
should I do
oh this what's the right thing to do God
[Music]
Frick fricky noona freakin Enoch y'all
boy
Oh No did you just need to get some
stress out
this needs displacement what I do what I
do I just wanted to be a screaming God
ah don't do the lives of the many
outweigh the slides of the yeah it's
hard to even tell if this world is real
but I don't think that matters because
[Music]
the entity has said that he can't go
against his programming and he's tried
to say you do realize what this world is
in terms of reality I think the game is
trying to show you that Nikko is a real
thing a person
but also it seems like this world is
inhabited with people and also robots
that are starting to figure out who they
are you know what I mean so it's a hard
conundrum is this a situation where the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few what is going to happen to Nico
if he returns the son does that mean
Nico would be trapped here forever torn
away from his family without a choice
why why that's the main question in my
mind why why was Nico torn from his
family what is this world that pulls
people in to do this and why does the
entity want to die is it because that
when the LAT son goes into that tower
it's going to power everything but it's
a horrible machine that Rob's the life
from random children plucked from
different universes is that an engine
worth continuing for the people that
live here maybe they're there arguably
millions and millions of people all
banking on this messiah being able to
save them the savior you know
[Music]
if I'm gonna act I'm gonna do this as if
I was in this situation if I were in
this situation even if it was a world
that I wasn't part of but a world that I
travelled through and I met people that
seemed good-hearted him and and
well-meaning and families that are torn
apart by the darkness in this world is
consuming itself if I were in that
derision I would I would put that light
bulb in no question about I'm not Nico
Nico has a family Nico Nico has a family
that he misses very dearly and his
friends and his hometown and it's unfair
that he was ripped here but God I have
to do what I would do in that situation
which I would return the Sun I would put
it in there I don't know what that means
for Nico but that's that's what I have
to do it's what I have to do it's what I
would do
you're right I can't just leave everyone
here to die thank you for your help
market but I didn't want to help [ __ ]
that's a good kid I promise I'll be okay
[Music]
oh just give me an achievement for
rebirth and that's it
oh is tell me there's something
[Music]
do something I could do no oh no is if I
open the game is it just gonna go to
that one because go to the same Zeit oh
god no oh that's the end ah see you have
a conundrum either way because if you
save Nico and send it back because I'm
assuming that he code died if you send
it back he has to live forever with the
guilt of destroying that entire world
ah okay I'm emotionally devastated I
need to go lie down
Oh oh boy okay alright so that is the
end of one shot I hope I did okay I hope
I did I don't know if I did I don't know
if I did Oh mummy ah [ __ ] okay so that's
it there's no more it ended just as
quickly as it began so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play for this game for yourself
I imagine there are different choices to
be made throughout it different choices
with infinite more meanings than what
you saw here and secrets and nooks and
crannies that you could explore I bet
and a beautiful story to be told
so beautiful and that's all I have to
say about it I'll let the experience
speak for itself there's no words that I
could put here to either comfort you or
explain more what happened it's
something that is what it is simply for
the choices that you make and that that
in and of itself is beautiful in its
simplicity so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]